hi i'm bella i'm here today with
buzzfeed i'm going to be reading thirst
tweet i'm not ready
okay
i'm a bella porch synth now where do i
begin do i buy bella themed socks or
some
bella themed socks for sure maybe a
shirt or something listen i'm down for
bella porch and i don't care what anyone
thinks her voice is amazing she's
adorable and i hope she does well in her
music career oh this is so sweet
so nice thank you not thirsty but i like
that what does bella porch feet look
like it's for a project can someone just
send me a picture please it's for a
project
um i'm pretty sure i i have a lot of
pictures out there of my feet but on
instagram if you look it up but um yeah
i let bella porch run me over several
times just so i can make sure her tires
are good to go wow
okay i let bella porch get me pregnant
honestly okay i do want kids
bella porch can have my whole soul and
both my kidneys if i have two i don't
even know how many i have do you need
two i think you only need one to survive
but i can sell your kidney to the black
market if you want me to
mommy sorry mommy sorry mommy sorry yes
honey do you want me to make you some
breakfast
need bella porch to choke me with the
metal arm
there is a picture of me of larae
choking me but i'm surprised i didn't
choke anybody with my metal arm
i want to eat bella porch respectfully
of course oh i like that it says
respectfully put me on a plate
i would let vela porch sit on my face
are you a chair are you a comfy chair
because i only do comfy chairs
bella porch can i lotion your toes
please
actually i don't actu i don't think i
lotion my toes so yeah sure bella porch
can choke me to death with her thighs
and i'd be honored to die to be honest i
think my thighs are strong enough i
guess we'll have to see
dreamt of falling asleep on bella
porch's boobs
these
there's nothing really there but
okay
bella porch fine as hell she need a spit
in my mouth oh
that's
that's
disgusting i'm down i need vowel porch
to crush my balls
i don't think that's nice for me to do
but also that's gonna hurt a lot but
with my platform boots i feel like i'm
so down i've never done that to anybody
so if you're down just hit me up i'll
crush your balls i would lose a limb and
bleach my eyeballs to have sex with pope
no comment
on that one i'd give up all of my toast
just for a whiff of bella porch her five
foot ass can choke my six three ass out
and i wouldn't even struggle you like
choking
i kind of like it too but
i'd let you cut me into pieces and eat
me mommy it would be my dream to provide
you with nutrition and be able to
explore your digestive tract and leave
your body through your anal cavity
that is so precise what
um i don't know what to say i'm just
like that's insane i would suck bella
porsche's butt plug
like a pacifier sucks suck
ew
i'm not really into
butt plugs no comment i
no
yeah that was a lot of thirsty
tweets i think it started really good
talking about how my voice was pretty i
really liked that and then it came to a
point where you're talking about about
plugs
okay it just like escalated quickly
thank you buzzfeed for having me really
had fun reading those thirsty tweets
my first ep dolls is out now so go check
that out thank you
[Music]
you